-Robert and I have
a lot of history together.
Not a lot of people know this,
but back in the early '90s,
we both starred in a commercial
for an allergy medicine
called Zynerma.
-Oh, my -- That's totally right.
-Remember that?
-Yeah, that
really eccentric director.
-Oh, don't even. The director.
-He came out of French cinema,
right?
-He did.
Well, he had this thing
that he wanted us
to have our line readings
be really fresh.
Right, so he didn't want us to
see our lines before the bit.
-That's right.
-So every time
we went to the commercial,
we were reading the lines
for the first time
right there on set.
Well, I found one
of our old commercials.
-No!
-Yes.
-Oh, it's about time.
-So, here for the first time
in decades is me
and Robert Downey Jr.'s ad
for Zynerma.
-Zynerma!
-If you suffer
from seasonal allergies,
then relief is finally here
with once-daily Zynerma.
Ask your doctor or pharmacist
if Zynerma is right for you.
-Before Zynerma,
my allergies would keep me
in bed all day long.
But not anymore.
Now the only thing
keeping in my bed
is my fear of tall men.
[ Laughter ]
-Side effects of Zynerma
may include thought blisters,
the mumps, hepatitis K,
gooberlycosis,
tripolar depression and slacks,
premature fatherhood,
stump lung, crispicks,
and hat failure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Best of all, they're shaped
like Flintstone characters.
Not the pills. My nipples.
♪♪
-Zynerma shouldn't replace
your asthma inhaler,
and it can't replace...her.
Sorry, big guy,
but she's not coming back.
The sooner you accept that, the
better off we're all gonna be.
♪♪
She actually wrote you
a really long letter
explaining everything,
but I accidentally
dropped it in the toilet.
My bad.
-Alright, now me and you
together.
-Okay.
♪♪
-Wait, give me a second.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, ready?
Zynerma let me live again,
because I was once declared
legally dead for 15 hours.
-If your erection lasts
more than four hours,
that has nothing to do
with Zynerma...
but congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What the...?
There's more?
Alright.
One time, I got a Lego man
stuck in my no--
[ Laughter ]
One time, I got a Lego man
stuck in my nose.
I blew and blew and blew,
but he wouldn't come out.
He's still up there to this day.
Sometimes when I'm lying in bed
at night, I think about him --
how old he is,
if he ever got married,
if he's happy.
Then the Ambien kicks in
and I fall asleep
naked in the front yard.
♪♪
-Whoa, I just
r-realized something.
Zynerma rhymes with potato.
Wait, no. Sorry.
Tomato rhymes with "pot-ah-to."
Damn it, I just
embarrassed myself again.
I guess my dry cleaner
was right --
I'm a worthless sack of crap.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Tad. Hey, Tad.
What are you up to, man?
-Hey, sorry, bro.
-[ Laughs ]
You know you can make --
Do you know you can make
your own homemade Tylenol?
All you need is Skittles
and vodka.
[ Laughter ]
-Ask your doctor
about Zynerma today,
then ask your doctor
for their number.
Doctors are good people to date
because they've already
seen you naked
and most of them
make a [bleep]load of money.
[ Laughter ]
-I asked my doctor if Zynerma
was right for me,
but he said, "I've never heard
of Zynerma. What is it?"
So I said, "It's a pill,
dum-dum.
Just write the prescription."
Then he said, "That's not
how prescriptions work."
So I said, "Pwease?"
And he said, "No."
So I said,
"Pwetty, pwetty pwease?"
And he said no again
and called the police.
So now I go to the veterinarian.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Here's a list of
everything I'm allergic to --
love...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I lived in the back of
a Walgreens for three years
because my arm was stuck
in the blood pressure machine.
-That's where I found him.
I took him home,
hosed him off in his yard
and nursed him back to health
with Muscle Milk.
-Soon, I weighed 600 pounds.
It was a long, hard road
to lose all that weight,
and I couldn't have done it
without a good friend.
-But after his friend escaped,
I stepped in.
The rest is
rock 'n' roll history.
-Thanks, Zynerma!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Once-daily Zynerma --
breathe deep.
♪♪
-Had a lot of...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got a lot of -- [ Laughs ]
-That went on a bit.
-We did a lot of commercials.
I forgot how many commercials
we ended up doing.
-Yeah. Very experimental.
-[ Laughs ]
My thanks to Robert Downey Jr.,
everybody.